Peter Brown here with a gamespot news  update today's sony announced its  selling off its stake in the final  fantasy developer square enix at a value  estimated at 47 million dollars you may  be surprised to learn that sony held a  stake in the company but in fact the  PlayStation Creator had investment since  the early 2000s they held 8.2 percent of  square enix's total shares this is yet  another phase in sony's major  streamlining process coming after  separate announcements to sell off its  pc division lay off thousands of  employees and sell to major office  buildings in Tokyo and New York City the  deal is expected to officially closed on  April 17 and there's no word yet on  whether or not this will directly impact  Square Enix in the near term we'll keep  you updated with any new announcements  on gamespot com